[Music]
i'm coming to y'all straight from rikers
penitentiary [ __ ]
you heard me hey man haters out there
think i'm playing i think i'm some kind
of joke man
young monday hell yeah take this out
right here man
i'm the baddest [ __ ] on this
whole prison here [ __ ]
yeah you're hurt check it out let's go
i'm the baddest dude
y'all need to watch your backyard
that's right yeah yeah yeah cause i'm
coming for y'all you know
what's up man i run this yeah in fact yo
let's go i'm the baddest where you going
man where you going hey man where you
going you ain't got to go
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i see pick on the little guy huh
punks hey i am this
little ironic [ __ ] right
[Music]
don't think we should be here this right
now
young man you know there's a time and a
[Music]
place
[Music]
yo
what do you think it is hey what's up
y'all oh
hey what you guys playing oh no just a
little dvd right uh what dvd uh it came
for you in the mail it says
to my fresh dope son from mcmahon
i can't wait to see it
hey if there's one thing we're gonna do
today we're playing that dvd
come on come on man oh yeah oh yes
oh god please man did you produce this
trash no no no
no no no no no no yo
i'm the m to the c to the m o m and when
it comes to mom rappers i'm the biggerty
best of them
sending out this rhyme to my homie
number one his name's carl stewart but
to me he's just the sun
word up oh okay so you got that running
man down come on can we please turn this
off
turn it up no yeah yeah i missed it
you left some stuff behind that i can
send you if you need like your best
friend bear and your magazines going
through all this stuff but it looks
pretty risky you use so much lotion but
your socks sure
are crispy
i've been cleaning with the broom and
the vacuum and found victoria's secret
is she's hiding in your room every nook
and cranny there are rods of tissue
i can't even open this swimsuit issue
what is wrong with you bro i spilt a
soda on that magazine right i i'm
getting your sheets so
nice and clean like when you wet your
bed till you were 16.
i overreacted sorry i spanked you look
another crispy sock
no thank you oh why oh she's sniffing
that is wrong how many crispy socks she
gonna find dog
crispy socks here crispy socks there
crispy socks with some mystery head
we're gonna turn it off right now come
on you guys
we started it we gonna finish
[Music]
oh all the bee changed up
i got the kitchen and the basement and
the living room and since your dad met
that [ __ ] i got his office too got my
juices going my rhymes flowing
my breath blowing showing the signs
flowing i can feel my skills growing
took a little practice to practice these
lyrical gymnastics but now the fact is
queen bee imma be throwing out your
mattress hell yeah
baddest [ __ ] in the biz taking the show
on the road you can clean up your own
chairs
peace
[Music]
put the [ __ ] on the chainx
[Music]
all y'all rappers out there think y'all
hard cause what y'all been through
hey y'all check it out it was friday
night chilling
on my front lawn me and my crew i had my
bathrobe on
everybody high just watched x-men
got plenty chicken heads ready for sex
man musters roll up
they trying to talk smack don't these
know
they [ __ ] with them
i knew homie seen us he pulled two shots
somehow my penis got between us i got
shot
[Music]
still standing
went back to my palace fast
now i'm the dude walking around with a
phallus cast like wolverine
i'm trying to be a loner but they think
a got an adamantium boner
what can i say they still up on my totem
pole
[ __ ] get your tongue ring away from the
scrotum hole
don't know why they love it but it keeps
the ladies moistening
gave half the honeys in the hood lead
poisoning
shot shot shot and i got shot in them
[Music]
shot me shot shot i got shot
but it's still standing
yo they shot that fool
[Music]
man damn that hurts
damn nah video over man video's over
i'm serious man damn yo yo up what up
what up welcome to battle rock you are
we're gonna battle rap
every day in the month of february y'all
yo i'm your host big pete paul
that's right to my left we got the
champion y'all introduced son yeah
what's happening this your boy rhino d
and i'm about the front hand backhand is
there something
that's right that's right that's right
we got the challenger introducing
something what's up man i'm dylan killer
in the house
100 usda pure me no filler right here
dude
okay okay okay yo dylan lost the toss so
you go first okay
gentlemen battle royale all right yeah
man here we go you shook
son imma eat you for breakfast cause i'm
a crook son i stole a cup of field from
your girl's breasts
you don't even know man hey listen man
you can't even win this 100 yard dash
but let me ask you a question what do
they call that a mustache
can you take it down a little bit on
what are you a horse
that's the last one yo what's up dog you
know my son is rich i'm swimming in
simoleons i mean what am i supposed to
do with this miniature black napoleon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Applause]
that's right man yo we got a champion
still we got a champions league
when i roll down the street brother's
all taking me honey's dropping their g's
running pieces of me cause i run this
whole block with these rhymes and this
glide make this whole damn hood tick
this my tongue i'm the toss
cockered the water i'm the boss and the
king [ __ ] kissing my ass and [ __ ]
kissing my ring
what's up yeah holy [ __ ] you know it's
true
i'm the leader of the free world
[Applause]
[Music]
using words and rhymes to get through
hard times
yeah come on
[Music]
i came from the streets with nothing in
my pockets no food
no picks no power in the sockets each
battle i fight a role model and a
teacher
hip hop my church every rapper a
preacher
i preach from my ass my farts is my
sermons the church is your mouth where i
shoot my holy sperm
you can take your role models roll them
on my meat [ __ ]
[Music]
but everywhere we go we don't forget the
struggle son black woman two jobs two
kids too time to juggle them
yum yum yummy titty titties
[Music]
titties in my mouth i got
check out leo's
i wonder what he's dreaming about he is
probably dreaming about what we is gonna
do to the team from the west
i wonder
[Music]
to variousness t king for short i'm a
bad mama jammer and an awful sport
smoochie wireless you could call me ty
royal wrapping up rushers like aluminum
foils the queen goldberry i'm very scary
if i got the ball
you best be wary la carpetron duke
marion
i love the ball so much i want to marry
[Music]
we are the best i'm
ibrahim and my rhymes are clean like my
name was dr seuss
hobo cuts the third they call me the
probe i can intercept balls with my elo
shower handle that's my name power
candle
sounds the same with jack marriott
[Music]
okay don't you know
[Music]
it must have been all a dream
or was it
[Music]
oh it's on
what's up y'all it's jefferson i'm the
big left tackle gonna help us
win x-wing at aliciousness
i'll use my force to give the east
distress ale good and spiders where it's
at
running through defenders and path is my
stats y'all know me
i'm washing beard catch so many balls
it's a little weird
cause you know we're gonna
[Music]
can't block me and all of that jazz
because y'all don't want none of this
automatize
the player tj aj formerly known
as mouse cop and dog i'm the touchdown
man that's grundle
but y'all ain't ready for my man dan
smith
yo yo smith comma daniel other kickers
in the league don't hold a candle
cheerleaders up i'm a chocolate crotches
goddamn baby cocker spaniel byu why you
be
back as the [ __ ] wanna get with me
gotta switch your sweets and dutchies
rolling in them summer team could touch
these hitting field goals blunted been
drunk when i punted been like a hundred
times
that i already done it oh see these
haters thought i was playing staying
away from my faces with all the books
they're saying
but just remember people talking when
you're tossing those gauntlets from dan
smith and the west is getting rowdy like
[Applause]
monsters
first things first i do not care
that you're a multi-platinum selling
rapper gun rack
what i care about is that i 100 know
that you murdered darnell simmons
so you better start talking
[Music]
yeah but you ain't got nothing oh
i you know i'm actually i'm very glad
that you said that
uh because respectfully i beg to differ
i killed darnell yeah i shot him with my
nine
i shot him nine times nine pm on the
dime
and by the way it was november night
i got a vivid imagination
i couldn't have shot done now i was at
my cousin's birthday party
red lobster november 9th 9.
at red lobster mm-hmm geez i got to tell
you gun right
i find that really hard to believe
i got an alibi first
when in reality i shot darnell like a
mobster
it's a lot anyone could tell this if you
know about my allergy to all
shelby just confess
conrad i confess that shellfish is the
only thing that rhymes with tell this
it's just words that that do
nouns adjectives they just happen to be
in a dope order but
we haven't got no pearl
shut up darnell with a long ass gun
and tossed it into the aquarium
[Music]
i have no idea what that object is
if i had to identify it i would call it
a gun of the long ass variety
some seaweed in there too look detective
i hate to break it to you i ain't
counting on it
i struck my chin real slow when i'm
lying
and i was laughing super hard as darnell
was dying
the name of the album is i killed
darnell simmons
it's a concept i want a concept that's a
picture of you
a picture of you and behind you is
target shipment's body
why is enough you're going away for a
long time you understand
you're gonna confess if it's the last
thing you ever do you hear me don't
wreck
i'll be your body he's free to go
what no no no no no we have everything
we need no it was simmons girlfriend she
just confessed to the whole thing
infidelity crime of passion
let's go mr rack
[Music]
[ __ ] i think you get the gist and when
you let me out i'm gonna blow a little
kiss
this is my confession it missable in
court
i killed darnell simmons for sport
[Music]
ow
[Music]
oh